can it reverse the fact that one in nine
people are actually on a waiting list
for hospital treatment in england
well trevor let's start with um the
impact on patients and i think it's
really important we talk a lot about the
statistics here but we just need to
remember that there are far too many
people who are waiting too long for
treatment as a result of the disruption
caused by covered and we just need to
remember that this means that there are
six million people who are in pain at
the worst end of things we know that
potentially these conditions can worsen
and potentially turn into um permanent
problems so every trust leader is
completely aware of the need to get
through these backlogs as quickly as
they possibly can we've worked very hard
on this plan it is stretching it is very
stretching i mean the um uh institute
for fiscal studies this week described
the headline ambition of getting to uh
around 130 percent of the levels of
activity in this area um by 2425
compared to what we were doing pre-code
it's a 30 increase in levels of activity
they described that as certainly
ambitious so we've set ourselves a very
stretching target
and we know that we're going to need to
really do a number of different things
to ensure that target is delivered the
bit the bit that's the complexity here
trevor and i think a lot of the media
coverage this week i found slightly
frustrating is the problem the nhs has
got if you look at the core uh waiting
list issue about how big the waiting
list is we simply don't know how many
extra patients who didn't come forward
during covid are going to come onto the
waiting list so we could be actually
delivering that 130
headline target which would be amazing
fantastic and yet the waiting list would
still be going up so we just need to be
careful about saying we're just going to
judge nhs performance solely by how big
the waiting list is because we know it
is likely to grow because all of those
people who didn't come forward during
kovid are going to come forward
well i want to come to that in a second
but um if we may can we just deal with
one if you like public service point
here one of the um the flagship aspects
of this new plan is my planned care
which is described as an online service
uh informing patients about waiting
times and how to prepare for treatment
and the idea is that this will
reduce cancellations can you just
quickly explain how it actually is going
to work
yeah so what we're basically saying is
that in order for patients to and
there's a i think quite an interesting
concept here called weight well they
need to know two or three things the
first is they need to know when are they
likely to get treated and that will
prevent hopefully large numbers of
communications going backwards and
forwards about exactly when the
treatment will happen then the second
bit would be um just we know that about
a third of cancellations are due to
people who've got conditions such as
diabetes high blood pressure where those
conditions haven't perhaps been managed
as well as they might be in the run-up
to an operation so we get to the
operation day and then they effectively
find that we have to cancel so part of
this is about providing and supporting
appropriate information to enable people
with those conditions to be in in the
state of health that we need them to be
at the point where the operation happens
and i think all of us in the nhs know
trevor that we are behind not just the
private sector but other public services
in terms of our use of digital part of
that has been the lack of investment
that we've been able to make but this is
a very good example of where we do need
to ensure that we support our
our patients to actually use our
services in a 21st century way so this
is um you know another way in which we
can increase and improve our use of
digital
well okay thank you for that um look
there are a number of new targets and we
still have to see how they're going to
be operated but
one of the questions that i think this
plan raises is that there are still
things that the health services have to
achieve before they get to these new
targets so for example
in august last year there was a record
high number of patients urgently
referred
by their gps waiting for over two months
for cancer treatment um
we know that cancer patients often don't
have two months to spare and we're not
even meeting the diagnosis targets yet i
mean
shouldn't we be thinking about getting
that stuff done before we introduce some
of these new things
yes and that's absolutely what we're
going to be doing we've made a very
clear commitment that we will prioritize
the most urgent cases of which as you
quite correctly identify and the most
urgent cancer cases are key and that's
why we've set ourselves a target that
seventy-five percent of g r g fee
referrals gp referrals for cancer
diagnosis uh will actually be seen
within um 28 days because we know that's
a really really important task one of
the issues we've got here trevor is that
if you're a trust leader and you've got
a very large number of people who are
waiting there is quite a sophisticated
but incredibly important operation to do
in terms of clinical prioritization and
when you talk to trust leaders what
they'll tell you is that they spend a
huge amount of time working with
frontline clinicians working with
computer computer systems patient
records to really identify uh in what
order we should be bringing patients in
and of course we will focus on those who
are um you know have the greatest
clinical priority those who are most in
urgent need but but this is in the
context of and now let's be really clear
about this nobody in the nhs would want
to see a waiting list of this size and
what's happened is we've had two
problems the first is we've had
insufficient capacity in the nhs after a
decade of the longest and deepest
financial squeeze in nhs history so the
so the waiting list were already growing
before we went into covid and then what
we've had is this huge disruption over
the covert period so these waiting lists
are are you know they're by far the
biggest we've seen for a very very long
time
we've spoken about this issue of
capacity before
and uh to the lay person that is a
problem about numbers of staff you're i
think 93 000 people showed overall
nearly 40 000 nurses short what can
possibly be done about that other than
perhaps
uh some really determined and
intentional recruitment uh from
other countries
well trevor you put your figure on it
really really well and we're just
literally in the process of finalizing
the health and care bill where there was
a whole bunch of us who were saying to
the government you have to have a proper
long-term workforce plan and if it takes
three years years to train a nurse and
13 years to train a consultant you have
a very significant lead time here so how
can you expect the nhs to have the right
level of workforce that it needs if it's
not got a proper workforce plan in place
and there's been an amendment that was
uh debated in the lords that was
originally proposed by jeremy hunt in
the commons which it's incredibly
important that we that we pass so the
answer trevor is that there is good news
down the track in that we are now seeing
very high higher levels of people
entering training but if i'm really
honest we've got this very difficult
period over the next two or three years
where we know we won't have enough staff
and you're absolutely right there will
be a significant premium on recruiting
people um from overseas but that's not a
comfortable place to be it also isn't
particularly helpful for the nations uh
from which we're um taking those staff
so we've got to have a proper workforce
plan and if i'm honest i'm incredibly
frustrated about the fact that the
government will not sign up to the idea
of a proper long-term workforce plan
which is what we have in every other
sector of our economy and what we have
in every other national health system i
can't understand why the government
won't sign up to what seems to me to be
blindingly obvious